LyssyTCHANSK concédant ce
"bastion stratégique" de l'est
- Lyssytchansk, dernière grande
ville disputée dans la région
de Louhansk, est à feu
et à sang. Bâtiments et maisons
sont calcinés. D'intenses
combats s'y tiennent depuis
des jours, l'assaut est violent,
Moscou souhaitant la prise
de cette ville-clé.
Et c'est ce que revendique
désormais la Russie.
"Ce à quoi nous aspirons
tous depuis huit longues années
est arrivé. Aujourd'hui,
nous avons libéré la ville
de Lyssytchansk", dit ce chef
séparatiste.
Cette avancée notable
est célébrée par les Russes,
qui contrôlent la moitié
du Donbass. Ces images
le confirment. On y voit
des soldats visiblement fiers,
ou encore cet homme, levant
un drapeau russe sur son balcon.
Dans une publication sur
Facebook, l'armée ukrainienne
confirme y avoir retiré ses
soldats pour préserver des vies,
reconnaissant la supériorité
militaire de l'ennemi.
Mais la situation demeure
confuse. À preuve, selon
le président Zelensky, il est
impossible d'affirmer que
Lyssytchansk est sous contrôle
russe.
Toujours dans l'Est, à quelques
kilomètres de la ligne de front,
des frappes sur Sloviansk
ont fait 6 morts et 15 blessés,
dont un enfant, selon le maire
de la ville.
Des dizaines d'incendies
se sont déclarés, notammtt
dans ce marché. Sloviansk
est sous forte pression russe,
certains la qualifient
de prochain lieu de bataille.
Même chose à Kramatorsk,
plus au sud. Tôt ce matin,
des bombardentnts ont d'ailleurs
retenti, sans faire de victimes
Des infrastructures civiles
ont néanmoins été lourdemment
endommagées.
Du côté russe, Moscou accuse
Kiev d'avoir tiré des missiles
à Belgorod, près
la frontière, tuant au moins
quatre personnes.
Ici Aimée mimieux,
Radio-Canada, Montréal